[Music]
Chuck what's the tallest mountain in the
world
um is it is it Everest
yeah yeah Mount Everest Mount Everest
and toss compared to what
K2
[Laughter]
only other possible answer you could
give in this session K2 that's K1 The
North Face that's it
that's all you got that's all you got
for me hey and any other any other
clothing that might uh like Patagonia or
anything that's that's all I know let me
tell you something let me tell you what
you will not find on the top of any
mountain
right here
okay you will not find no no you could
you could write you
you could go if there's snow on the
mountain that's not a mountain you're
gonna be on yeah you could go to win
Martin Luther King's Mountain where he
sees the promises
didn't have snow
I gotta tell brother martin I'm sorry
I'm I'ma wave to you from the bottom
base camp
I'm gonna wait for you I'm gonna wait
for you to get back down here and tell
me everything's okay
I've been into the Mountaintop and I'm
like good for you can you take a picture
put it on Instagram I would like to see
it okay he would say no not Mount
Everest I'm talking about that other
mountain with no snow yeah
all right so how do they measure the
height of it's the height relative to
what
uh oh well they always say sea level
exactly hide above sea level okay
well how high is sea level
okay have you thought about that I I
gotta tell you the truth
I'm gonna be honest and I'm I'm really
ashamed of this right now
I have never thought about that once in
my life like okay and it's a 15 feet
above sea level
well hi how is sea level
well what are you writing a book you
smart ass shut up it's 15 feet above sea
level
how high is sea level it's an important
question okay if
no land came above the ocean level okay
okay and the whole earth were just sea
levels because Earth is not a perfect
sphere
the parts of the sea that's at the
equator
will be farther away from Earth's center
than the parts of the sea that are at
the poles so sea level is not an
equidistant thing from the center of the
Earth
all right are we okay with that so far
that makes sense
can you handle the truth here okay so
Earth is slightly flattened at the poles
and slightly fatter
at the Equator so if you measure the
diameter of Earth at the equator
it is several thousand miles wider than
the distance from the North Pole to the
South Pole
okay got that all right okay not only
that Earth is slightly wider below the
equator than at the equator now we a
little Bonita Apple Bottom we went a
little bit we are pear-shaped we are
hair shaped okay what that means is if
you're a mountain okay near the equator
you get a few extra Thousand Miles Head
Start if you're in the competition for
the tip of the mountain being farthest
from Earth Center
aha I got you you get it several
thousand okay so ask me what is the
highest mountain from Earth Center what
is the highest mountain from Earth
Center
it is not Mount Everest itself is the
tenth highest Summit from Earth Center
10th let me guess
the highest mountain from Center
is somewhere in Africa
okay so that's a good guess it's wrong
but a really excellent guess
um
it's completely wrong but it's a good
guess okay okay okay go ahead top five
Peaks the top five Peaks
the distance from Earth Center are all
in South America oh the number one thing
is yes Mount
Chimborazo Chimborazo
Ecuador guess what the latitude is of
Ecuador zero maybe because yeah
not a coincidence oh wow so so this
mountain is one degree south of the
equator in Ecuador
okay and then Peru has the next two and
then Ecuador again and then Peru and
then the sixth highest Summit
from the center of the earth is indeed
in Africa and just name it quickly even
if you guess oh now killing jarrow
Kilimanjaro there it is so South America
has eight of the top 10 Peaks uh Africa
has the sixth highest peak against earth
center and then Mount Everest coming in
at 10th in Asia
what's eight and nine like two three
story buildings in Ecuador
yes
okay and another thing about Chim
Bizarro it's the it's the cone of a
dormant volcano oh so I think it has the
highest Ascent from its base of any
mountain in the world other than certain
volcanic mountains that begin at the
bottom of the ocean such as the big
island of Hawaii that's the single
biggest mountain on Earth but most of it
is below sea level okay so chimpazar
Rises up very quite impressively as a
result of this whereas K1
uh you know K1 is like slightly higher
than K2 and the entire Himalayan
Mountain Range it helps the all the
Peaks out right so you don't see this
major Ascent from the base as you
otherwise would right so I'm just saying
that's that's that's that's how that's
that's what it looks like and at the top
of that Peak you would weigh way less
than at any other place on Earth not
only because you're farthest from Earth
Center you are also near the equator and
the spinning Earth is trying to fling
you off so there's a centrifugal force
as well
so that is the lightest you could
possibly weigh relative to if you were
standing on the North Pole
well I'm going there as soon as I can
just told me my next place to live just
to lose some weight is that what you're
saying yeah listen that's so much better
than what I'm trying to do now you know
but but if I just plunk you there you
would have lost weight but you would not
have gotten any smaller
ah well you can't have everything
because you know Weight Watchers is
really Mass Watchers right right if you
want to lose weight you can just go to
the top of a mountain or just go into
space or go on to the Moon you'll lose
weight there immediately but you'll
still carry all the fat that you might
have been trying to get rid of so really
like I said Weight Watchers is a mass
Watchers you want to lose weight you're
really trying to lose Mass just trying
to put it out there we gotta go all
right there you go that was that was
very cool very cool check my co-host in
all these matters especially the
explainer ones as always keep looking up
foreign
[Music]